une bulle d'évasion pour ces familles
ukrainienne réfugiés pour la cinquième
fois ce 4 juin les ateliers créatifs et
solidaire était organisée par des
bénévoles à maisons laffitte l'occasion
d'accueillir parents et enfants pour un
moment de convivialité avec caroline le
samedi on propose ses ateliers donc
voilà qui sont donc il ya un atelier
créatif le mieux c'est la partie plutôt
bien être en mouvement l'idée fait
vraiment d'aller se sentir à l'aise dans
son corps et puis en même temps de
pouvoir pratiquer et d'apprendre la
langue française qui tombe tout en étant
au mouvement parce que moi je suis
passionné par le mouvement dans les
accostages favoriser des interactions
favoriser les échanges créer un groupe
créé dû créer du lien en fait entre
entre les mamans et puis aussi entre
nous parce qu'en fait le bénéfice ou le
cours nous tous eus pendant que les
enfants développent leur créativité les
mamans ont le droit à un instant de
détente avec une masseuse
professionnelle insfp elle évite la
manche fait du massage c'est super
agréable mais je me dis tout ce qu'on
peut faire qui peut changer un petit peu
voilà ajoutez un petit peu de bien-être
et de douceur julian a déjà vécu en
france pendant deux ans il a quelques
années à cause de la guerre elle a dû
revenir avec sa mère et son frère
s'installer ici
ces ateliers créatifs et solidaires sont
une bulle d'oxygène
ça c'est très agréable
inna est venu en france avec son mari et
sa fille juste avant la guerre pour elle
ces activités permettent de nouer de
nouveaux liens il faut avoir
c'est très important pour cette appli
est là parce que les écolos on peut
parler les enfants peuvent s'amuser
terre éventuels commentaires ils sont
avec nous et
et je veux qu'on soit ensemble en
famille ici et j'espère que ça va a
terminé la guerre
organisé depuis le 7 mai ces activités
auront permis d'accueillir en moyenne 20
craignent un chaque samedi les ateliers
se poursuivent tout l'été afin de
conserver le lien avec les familles